the US government is expected to borrow
$2 trillion a year for the next decade
that's huge and unprecedented investors
are starting to think that all this
borrowing could have some major impacts
on stocks bonds and all kinds of other
Investments I'm going to explain why the
government is borrowing so much money
while that borrowing will impact markets
and what this could mean for the
investing world in the near future let's
get into it the US national debt
recently hit $33 trillion the
Congressional budget office estimates
our debt could surpass $40 trillion in 5
years that's because even though the
government isn't rolling out any big new
stimulus programs it is bringing in a
lot less Revenue than it did over the
past 2 years revenue is basically
shorthand for taxes the government is
collecting less taxes because people are
collecting less capital gains on the
sale of things like stocks businesses
and houses remember you pay taxes in the
year following taxable events so the tax
taxes from Big stock and housing market
gains we saw in 2021 were largely
recorded in fiscal year 2022 the
government is also paying a lot more in
interest so it can borrow money to pay
for the deficit the interest rate on
2-year government bonds at the beginning
of 2022 was less than 1% now that rate
is over 5% when you're paying interest
on billions or trillions of dollars in
debt that difference adds up jeffy's us
Economist Thomas Simons is expecting the
government to issue just under $44
trillion in medium and long-term debt in
fiscal year 2024 and it's going to have
to sell that debt at the same time that
some of the largest buyers are cutting
back the Federal Reserve is the largest
holder of Treasury bonds but the US
Central Bank is projected to reduce its
Holdings by up to $60 billion per month
moving forward and the latest report
from the treasury Department shows China
cut its Holdings of US government bonds
to the lowest level since May 2009 China
was the the largest foreign holder of US
Government debt as recently as 2019 and
held more than $1 trillion in treasuries
in early 2021 but the country has
reduced its Holdings by almost $300
billion since then when there's more
Supply and less demand that usually
means that prices fall for bonds it also
means that yields rise treasury yields
reach their highest level in more than
15 years in September and the mountain
of new debt that's coming could push
them even higher higher yields
historically increase the value of the
dollar and boost the attractiveness of
safe assets like money market funds
retail Traders and professional money
managers have pushed a record amount of
cash into money market funds which are
paying the highest interest rates in
decades higher yields also have made
investments in Risky assets like stocks
less attractive the thinking goes that
if you can get a guaranteed 5% return on
an asset that's a lot like a savings
count why take the risk on stocks and
because most public companies have to
borrow money by issuing bonds their
costs will go up which often makes them
less profitable this is especially true
for so-called growth stocks these are
usually tech companies that have very
high Market valuations even though they
don't make a lot of profit Tech has made
up an increasingly large share of The
Benchmark S&P 500 stock index and is the
backbone of the NASDAQ with the outlook
for the economy uncertain you could see
more investors start to favor parking
their money with the US government or
leaving it in Money Market
funds